african and indian students stuck in
ukraine are accusing officials of
discriminating against them and pushing
them back from getting to the border
videos have been posted on social media
said to show black people being
prevented from boarding a train
and left stranded at a railway station
in levive as ukrainians were allowed on
others said they were turned back from
the border and were even being shot at
like this video indian students claim
ukrainian guards on the polish border
beat them up and didn't allow them to
cross tens of thousands of international
students have been stuck in ukraine
since the war started
on skype with us now from warsaw is
monica uh matus a human rights activist
working for the ngo group granica uh
monica thank you for your time
in your opinion what's happening here
why why would i mean there's a lot of
international students in ukraine as
i've learned why the discrimination
against them
uh we think it's really just uh honestly
uh on first of all i think it's on both
sides so the ukrainians are the
ukrainian border guards are preventing
people from passing through
and then the polish border guards are
not better um
you know in this in this case they are
also
actually stopping people and not letting
them in
we don't know why exactly i mean i think
it's just a question of not having
ukrainian passport we hear about um
students from african countries
uh from india from many other asian
countries
we also hear about people
from countries that
you know the people who actually were
trying um
to flee the war in other countries so
yemen and syria there's also people
right now we are solving the case of a
yemeni boy who is stuck
at the border in medica
who is trying to pass through and there
has been huge issues and problems to let
him actually enter poland i don't know
if it's sold yet right now because we
are just i've just been on the phone
about this case
and so um i don't know what's exactly
the reason i think it's really just an
issue of not having ukrainian passport
and i just want to add that uh you know
the racism from
at least polish uh government and polish
authorities
has been widely known already we
criticized
the fact that
you know the border patrol is actually
still operating on the northern uh
polish belarusian border and they are
still not letting people in and apply
for asylum whereas we are um rightly so
allowing uh ukrainians fleeing war
you know enter eu without any issues
without any problems this is this is
bluntly unfair i think
do you know if any uh government any
officials from either side are actually
acknowledging there's an issue there or
to them are they just viewing it as
well it's a chaotic situation we're
suddenly in a war situation and and
there's so many people flooding the
borders
uh i i cannot speak for uh ukrainian uh
border border guards but um
the polish border patrol and yesterday
they issued a very short statement on
twitter i think in reaction to all of
those uh videos
and news on social media saying that we
need to stay stay stop fake news because
it's actually fake and they are allowing
everybody in well i mean maybe it is
true maybe they are allowing everybody
um in but it actually takes uh
quite much much much longer time for
people without ukrainian passports to
cross the border and quite often they
are moved back to the end of the queue
monica thank you so much for your time
another uh part of this story which we
must address and we thank you for your
expertise
thank you